the latest on Carrie Fisher a source  close to the Fisher family tells ET and  the insider that Carrie has been  cremated some of her ashes will be  buried with mom Debbie Reynolds a  private memorial for the Star Wars  actress is slated for Thursday on Friday  Carrie's mother will be laid to rest in  Los Angeles the source also says a  public memorial will be planned for  months down the road while nothing has  been finalized our source adds that Tom  Hanks Carrie's ex-husband Paul Simon and  Meryl Streep are among the invited  guests Meryl of course played a version  of Carrie in the movie postcards from  the edge  I've always been less mad at you mama  meanwhile the LA coroner tells et that a  security hold has been placed on the  late actresses autopsy report that means  no information will be released to the  public at this time et has learned that  a hold is common for high-profile  celebrity deaths  you